i am honored to be here today to present
at the 2022 picon germany and pi data
berlin conference i have never been to
berlin and i hope one day to make it
there
i'm going to do a brief introduction
about myself and then i'm going to go
into the sprints the in-person
experience the evolution of the
in-person spins and over to the online
sprint and the lessons learned in open
source
my name is reish mashaik i was born in
india and moved to the us when i was six
years old i attended breakfast the state
university of new jersey for both my
undergrad and master's in statistics i
worked as a biostatistician in the
pharmaceutical industry for over 10
years and i have an mba from nyu stern
school of business i'm particularly
excited to present here because back in
november of 2019 i submitted a cfp to pi
data nyc to speak about the sprint i had
organized up until that time there had
been five and my cfp was not accepted so
i'm really really happy to be here new
york's a tough crowd
you can find me on twitter github and
linkedin at
richmond i've been doing community work
in the pi data space for over seven
years
some of you may know me from um the
documentation that i wrote up for fast
ai
um i was a diversity chair for jupiter
con 2020 which you may remember was
supposed to be in berlin but pivoted to
online
uh maybe you may have read some of my
blogs such as why women are flourishing
the art community but lagging in python
i've been an organizer for the new york
city chapter of pride ladies in 2019 i
received the non-focused community
service award and they're the
scikit-learn open source sprint which is
what today's keynote is on
some background of my community work i
was an active organizer and contributor
to the women's group focus on machine
learning and data science and about two
and a half years ago i founded a data
model
i'm also on the scikit-learn contributor
experience team
a little bit about data umbrella it's a
global community for underrepresented
persons in data science what we do is we
organize events on data science and open
source we organize open source spins
some people know them as hackathons and
we create curate resources for the
community on data science and inclusive
practices all levels are welcome
beginners and experts and data umbrella
is a fiscally sponsored project of open
collective which is a registered 501c3
nonprofit based in california
there are various ways to connect with
data umbrella our meetup group has
upcoming events listed we have a webinar
library on youtube and you can follow us
on twitter at data umbrella one word
before i dive in i want to acknowledge
all the folks over the years who have
been involved in this sprint there have
been many many people who have
contributed to this friends i'd like to
thank all the organizers and volunteers
a special thanks to the scikit-learn
team for patiently reviewing pro
requests by so many beginner
contributors and i'd like to thank the
community for joining and contributing
at the sprints with so much enthusiasm
this keynote is one person's perspective
on the scrims that is mine
how did the sprint get started so i met
andreas who was a core developer on the
scikit-learn team at a pi data nyc back
in 2015 and i had invited him to do a
workshop on psychic learn to my meetup
group which he so kindly did
and so um
several months later i received an email
from andreas
hi reshma i'm applying for an nsf grant
and as part of that i'd like to do an
annual second learning beginner sprint
at nyc particularly targeted at women
we did this work in boston i was very
successful in showing people how to
contribute to open source software
i'd like to do this again and on a
regular basis
probably starting with second learn but
also trying to involve other python
projects
i'm writing to you to ask if you and
your group would be interested in
getting involved
to get the funding it would be great if
i could get a statement of collaboration
from you saying that if i get the
funding your group would participate in
a sprinting outreach
thanks andy
i thought to myself what is the sprint
exactly
um and what i did was i wrote back and
said hey andy that sounds amazing and
something that would be great for us to
be involved in we would love to learn
more details about it
so what i've learned is that a
scikit-learn sprint is a hands-on
hackathon or workshop where we work on
issues in the scikit-learn github
repository
we work with a pair programming partner
and we learn to contribute to open
source and some of the prerequisites are
having a github account having some
knowledge of python and scikit-learn and
it's helpful to have some experience
with git as well
the objectives of this spread were to
increase diversity in open source and
also one of the goals was to increase
diversity with long-term contributors
and the types of contributions
that
participants would make in the sprint
would be easy issues
documentation
reporting bugs or opening up issues
i also did an interview with andreas um
right before the first sprint and uh he
had also indicated that
there's one woman in the top 100
contributors to the scikit-learn
language
so the first sprint happened it was in
march of 2017 in new york city
and then the second sprint um we
organized
it was in september of 2018 in new york
city as well
this is my very first pull request to
psychic learned it was a code
contribution and even though it was
labeled quote easy it was pretty hard
for me
you can see um at the conversation um
left that there are about 35
items in the thread
and it took me two months to complete
that um
i should have started with a
documentation contribution but i spent
the first couple of hours of sprint
running around and i missed andrea's
sprint into a presentation
so we observed some challenges with this
sprint um the first was that it was
listed as a general meetup event and you
know there were a couple of people who
attended the sprint without a laptop so
they weren't able to contribute
um some of the attendees had little or
no knowledge of python or scikit-learn
and it wasn't the best use of our time
some attendees don't read the meetup
event description and the prerequisites
and so they left early and we had a long
wait list and so it was a shame that
some other people couldn't have joined
and about a month after the sprint i
received another email from andreas
mueller
hey
is there a way we can follow up on the
prs from the sprint
see what has happened and what is solved
we have a list or should we just go by
date
cheers andy
so um i followed up with the script
folks i sent numerous emails via meetup
linkedin and not a single response
so what happens when contributors are at
a spin and they don't follow up on their
work um it's not great for the
maintainers because people started work
that was unfinished
and to be fair we hadn't communicated
that at the sprint so we were learning
along the way too
i reached out to folks in the community
that i knew that had participated in
either the 2017 or 2018 sprint and asked
if they would assist in finishing up
some of the pr's that were open and
these three lovely women helped with the
prs melissa tache and kat
as well i also worked on a few of the
open pr's with the sprint which was
great practice for me and the majority
of those were documentation
so some observations from the sprints is
that interest level is high in the
community there are a lot of people who
want to contribute
and also attrition is high
and so it's sort of challenging to sort
of estimate how many people are going to
attend
um and also you know with um
people not following up on their work
and they also sort of missed out on the
experience of finishing up the pull
request and the satisfaction of having
their pull request
which is amazing
so after those two sprints i wrote up
sprint impact reports um and it's about
you know how many people attended how
many prs they worked on and some lessons
learned and it was good to be able to
share that with the community and i
published that um in january of 2018.
so results from these sprints are not
easily measurable and occasionally some
become apparent somebody named emily
thompson read my sprint report and
organized a sprint with her friends to
contribute to scikit-learn so that's
really great
um and then in february 2019 tanya
allard
i had shared my report with the
non-focused disc committee which is a
diversity and scientific reviewing and
so she sent me an email and said thanks
for sharing this with us i'm organizing
a mentor expect for gender minorities in
the python community as part of icon
2019. if you have some time i would love
to pick your brains around the lessons
learned and general suggestions you
might have and so it's been good to be
able to share what i've learned with the
community thus far and i learned that
documentation is important and impactful
and it's good to see that
people are finding their way to it
now let's look at the evolution of the
in-person sprints in 2018.
we implemented the application form and
what that did was it required
participants to read and agree to do
some prep work
we also communicated about following up
with work that it was part of the
process of contributing that would take
a while for their prs to be reviewed and
so um finishing you know encouraging
people to finish up on their pull
requests and you know letting people
know that it does take some
time we encourage documentation for
first-time contributors
and so with this adjustment um i also
increased communication a lot more
emails
a lot of
some announcements on twitter
encouraging new yorkers to get enough
sleep and save their partying for
saturday night after the sprint and to
arrive on time so they don't miss the
introduction
and watch their emails for updates
was a third sprint that was um organized
and which was the first one for 2019
which was in nairobi at
nairobi kenya after discovering there's
a very active tech and data science
community there
so how do you find a scikit-learn
maintainer to travel to run the sprint
in nairobi well i discovered that there
is a scikit-learn mailing list and i
asked on there and i connected with
adrian jalali who is also somebody who
lives in berlin and you may know him
because he is one of the organizers of
this conference
so the sprint happened um there is
miriam there on the right who was
the on ground organizer there and um
they all had a great time and a dream
traveled all the way from berlin to
nairobi
so the next sprint which is number four
was in new york so that was the third
sprint in person in new york
and um
you know we had 45 sprint attendance
which was a really large crowd even with
the luxury of having three core
developers in the city of new york it
was a pretty busy and intense day and we
had very very serious contributors
in fact i may have over booked and had
and had too many contributors um we were
pretty exhausted but the maintainers
were pretty exhausted
um
and so you know we celebrated the
chinese finish the sprint and the
organizers too
and so the sprint number five which was
the third sprint in san francisco
happened in november it was loads of fun
um san francisco people are a bit more
relaxed than the new yorkers they take
long breaks and enjoy chatting with each
other during lunch
so the results of these adjustments for
the in-person sprints in 2019 are as
follows
the majority of sprint pull requests and
work has been completed which is um
remarkable and wonderful
new contributors see satisfaction
experience of having their pull requests
merged in the maintainers are a lot
happier to see their contributions
through
in lieu of increasing the number of open
prs in the repo
there's one challenge with these
adjustments which is that it puts a
greater burden on the organizer to do
more screening and communicating for the
scripts
meanwhile in berlin berlin is a perfect
place for an in-person spirit because
one of the core developers lived there a
dream and noah tamir and i connected and
i shared my experiences and resources
with her such as the application and
such and you know i want to congratulate
the berlin team for organizing the
sprint
now we have the pivot to the online
scripts so we had one two three four
five that i organized there was the
berlin sprint and for each of these
sprints there's about 30 to 40
participants
so in 2020 there was an in-person sprint
fund for june in new york city and then
the pandemic hit
and
upon realizing that the pandemic would
last throughout the year um you know my
goal was to have at least one in-person
sprint a year in new york
and with that i explored the possibility
of having an online sprint
so what prompted the move to the online
sprints well there was the pandemic
there had been a lot of inquiries from
people who found out about those sprints
from areas outside of new york and
outside of the united states that said
you know how could they participate in
the sprint
i had given you know i was really
considering providing opportunities for
folks outside of metropolitan regions
particularly the global south and also
with my move to data umbrella the
mission um it lined up with the mission
of data
and the mission of data umbrella is that
thinking globally is important and
imperative
as i mentioned before i was part of a
women's group before and i pivoted over
there i think intersectional diversity
is important which considers dimensions
of diversity in addition to gender
um and that welcoming including allies
is crucial in moving the needle on
diversity outcomes particularly in open
source
so in june of 2020 was the first online
spin which
will refer to as the pilot sprint and
then in 2021 we had three online sprints
two of them were focused on africa and
the middle east and one in blackmail
you can see from this map on the left
where the core developers the library
are located the majority are in france
which is where the library was created
there are some in the united states on
the east and west coast one in china one
in australia
and with these sprints the online
sprints that with the focus on um latin
america africa and the global online
spent you can see that participants um
joined from a variety of countries
uh this is just a listing of some of the
countries where people join from
next i'm going to discuss some of the
lessons learned
so what we learned as maintainers and
organizers of the sprint is that
continuing documentation which is the
text that's available can be
intimidating or inaccessible
there are other mediums such as videos
and written transcripts of those videos
which as supplements can be more
accessible and in fact are more
accessible
we discovered that we needed
translations for the latin america
sprint
these springs provide an opportunity to
the core development team to receive
feedback on documentation and improve
the process
and that regular bi-weekly office hours
are helpful after the sprint
um we also learned that there are some
open source barriers to entry for
instance um get you know contributors
may know python machine learning they
may not know it so well um familiarity
with rstv structured text which is
the documentation format that is used
for a lot of python libraries for
documents
documentation
um there are issues that um you know
they could be better labeled or
accessible to uh contributors on where
they can begin or work on
so you know contributing documentation
is available and yet you know a lot of
people still don't know exactly where to
begin contributing
so andreas um
created about a half hour video for a
crash course in contributing to open
source projects
and one of the reasons we did that is
because the sprint is typically eight
hours uh an in-person spin is eight
hours but it's really tough to have
people online for eight hours so this
allows people to review
the video prior to the sprint and break
up
the timing at their convenience
and that video has 3.7 000 views and you
know what this indicates that is that
these resources are helpful for people
who don't attend sprint
because not not everybody can
i also created a short video of step by
step instructions on a pull request to
psychic learn
and that video has 1.4 thousand views
uh i reached out to melissa weber
because um i realized with my
contributing experience that it was
important to understand stinks a bit
better for documentation contributions
and so melissa did a fabulous webinar
for the data umbrella team
community and her video right now has
5.6 000 views it's been immensely
popular
um i also reached out to thomas stan who
is a maintainer of psychic learn and um
there were you know some questions that
had to come up throughout
throughout the sprints and just general
knowledge that would be helpful for the
community and so he's done a fabulous
presentation on three components of the
very full request
and that video has about 700 views and
it's a really great video and i
encourage
you to check it out
um and here i'm sharing the experience
of a couple of our sprint participants
anna police from venezuela and fortune
from nigeria
so in the next section i'm going to
go over behind the scenes what it takes
to run the online open source
so pre and post print office hours are
helpful uh the sprint is four hours so a
week before we do pre-sprint office
hours for one hour and two weeks after
the sprint we do one hour office hours
to answer any questions on open vrs
there's a sprint prep checklist where
people can go through and watch the
videos and take notes and look at the
transcripts and translations if they
need them
we do pair programming and character
programming has been received with um a
lot of favorable comments um
and enthusiasm more so than we ever we
get a lot of positive feedback more so
than we ever did in the in-person
sprints
repeat sprints are helpful so people can
continue to return until they get on a
cadence of contributing and having
curated issues on github is also helpful
um there's also the engagement of
long-term contributors uh when i see
people um
contributing after the sprint and this
is really an imperfect way to find
people and um
i invite them to join the next sprint
whether they are located in that region
of interest or not and so we have at
least four people um
probably more um
who have been continuing to contribute
from their first sprint
so the objectives of the sprints did we
meet them did we increase diversity in
scikit-learn um
i don't know exactly how do we measure
that
um
did we increase diversity with long-term
contributors we seem to have made a
small dent but wow it took a while to
get there and it was with a tremendous
amount of effort
you know so i've organized almost 10
sprints i attend a lot of sprints with
pi data global pi cascades jupiter con
you know the mba side of me jokes that
it's for competitive intelligence but
really is to research and learn from
other projects and make adjustments
so i want to share some observations
from my experience in contributing to
open source
using open source projects and observing
the activity in the scikit-learn
repository as well as
the conversation on social media
particularly twitter
i think these suggestions will be
beneficial to the whole community
whether they are
contributors to a library whether
they're consumers of open source whether
they're maintainers
um the first thing that i would say is
that these practices will help um
everybody which is that reading the
contributing guide actually this is for
the contributors be the contributing
guide there's a lot of good information
in there
before jumping in and before jumping
into an issue really read it through
thoroughly from the top to the modern
and see what the discussion has been
thus far
the other thing that i learned along the
way is that nadia has written this
amazing amazing piece of work called
roads and bridges which is the unseen
labor behind our digital infrastructure
it is 140 pages but it's been the best
investment of my time and being more
informed about open source and i highly
recommend it and i'd like to share jeff
chopra's philosophy on you know
contributing and being part of the open
source community which is leave the
campsite better than you found it
there are other ways that um people can
contribute to open source not just by
you know submitting a pull request which
is donating to the open source project
you can also donate you can donate via
github sponsors via focus you can also
donate via benevity which is a company
sponsored matching program
you can you know sponsor the project for
one of your favorite maintainers
you can ask your employer to donate to
projects used by your company you can
also donate to communities such as data
umbrella or pi ladies
um i think it's also important to sort
of
recognize that contributing open source
is more than code there's documentation
there's reviewing full requests and
opening up issues there's helping out
with website updates for people who have
css and html skills
there is um so doing social media for
libraries um and we see that new teams
are emerging in open source projects
such as communications triaging websites
setting up a blog organizing events such
as sprints
um so you know some of the observations
that i've
observed and i think that are good to
share is
a lot of the projects have a mailing
list so do join the mailing list and
first assume the observed communication
style and then ask instead of jumping
directly into a list server and not
really knowing how it functions
um you know it's important to use
inclusive language um don't use a hello
sir assuming that the person who is on
this issue is a man um when using terms
like dear slash madam it excludes
non-binary persons and also hello guys
hey guys is not so inclusive
um you know when people if they run into
issues with the library um contribute by
opening up issues using constructive
language to move
the issue forward um complaining on
twitter with language like this library
is stupid is is not um it's not as
constructive
um and as mentioned before do read
through the github issue first before
jumping in um and it takes a while to
receive a response so do ping politely
after a reasonable amount of time for
people who have opened up a pr i don't
expect an immediate response
um you know do be an informed and
educated open source consumer and
contributor will be a draft banking
and you know what open source projects
are slowly discovering is that they're
also recognizing that non-code
contributions are essential to moving
their projects forward and that
providing non-traditional ongrams to
contributing such as videos and
transcripts and welcoming other skills
such as communications documentation and
website
there are some cascading impact the 2020
online students which is that juan
martin loyola of argentina was invited
to the contributor experience team
for scikit-learn
he was a really avid contributor and
very very helpful to
the community
for the participants of the students
um marin westman who's located in berlin
has taken what she's learned from her
community to the pi ladies berlin hack
nights as well as continuing to
contribute to scikit-learn and we have
we have a um we have a group of
returning contributors that come to the
office hours and
contribute to the library
i'd like to thank all the corporate
sponsors who have supported experience
over the years by providing venue
space for food or books
i'd like to really thank particularly
the code for science and society and the
more foundation for providing fiscal
support of the three online sprints in
2021 i would like to thank czi for
supporting david limbaugh with the two
year grant
and i really want to thank the pycon
germany and pi data berlin
for organizing this conference and the
invitation to speak you can find me at
rachma s on twitter github and linkedin
again if you want to connect with data
umbrella we're on meetup and youtube
[Music]
hello
well thank you for the talk um we have a
few questions already on slido
the first one is do you have any
upcoming online streams and how to
participate
yes there is a upcoming online sprint
for the numpai um library in june
and um the best way to find out about
that sprint is to join our meetup group
data umbrella or follow us on twitter or
sign up for our newsletter
cool
um we have another one
how can core developers make it easier
for people to contribute
so
a few things having a variety of
different ways that
people can
documentation for example videos some
simpler
documentation for contributing
having office hours um where people can
ask questions um
in real time
nice um and another one do you organize
well i guess you did answer that already
do you organize sprints for other
libraries and can they reach out to you
to organize sprints
so this is something that i have been uh
looking into and considering uh it it
does take a tremendous effort to do a
spin and so i've been thinking of what
are ways to scale it what are ways for
other projects to
to learn about it and it's something
that i'm working on and i haven't quite
found a way that is
scalable and with the with the resources
that i have to be able to provide that
for the interest level that is out there
yet
um
do people who sit here can like how can
they help you
if you don't have the bandwidth
how can they help um
that's a good question um there's a lot
of i would say there's a lot of help
needed in terms of organizing the
sprints a lot of a lot of administrative
work in terms of applications websites
dealing with spreadsheets
getting materials together
things like that pretty much
it's organizing a small mini conference
so
a fair point
um so how much has cyclone improved
through this friends
so you know
improvement in a way is difficult to
measure i you know i asked myself the
question um i had a nice long discussion
with andy uh andy muller and so um and
with other people too and it's difficult
to measure but i guess one question that
i asked is what what would it look like
if in the past
five six years that none of these
sprints ever happened right i believe
scikit-learn has over 2000 contributors
to the library i would say two three
four hundred of those came in through
the sprints maybe two three hundred and
so you know what would it look like um
without the sprints i i believe it's i
believe it's made a difference even in
terms of
the
video views that people have been able
to access who weren't even attending
attendees of the sprint
yeah fair
are sprint suited for less experienced
programmers
i think that i would say yes they can be
um i you know i i see that marin
westerman in berlin is organizing hack
nights i think i think shorter events um
regular events can probably build up
experience that's needed i know that for
instance the pandas library pi data and
pi ladies london have about monthly um
meetups where they spend two or three
hours online
as contributing to panda so that's like
another variation of how to contribute
to a library without doing an official
sprint
nice
um can a company organize an internal
open source print would there be support
for that from already experienced
maintainers
so that you know that is a really good
question i have seen companies reach out
and say that we would like to organize a
sprint
um and it's it's really you know a
commendable initiative i think that one
one dimension that is not considered in
that is that
maintainers need to be involved in this
sprint as well for instance um the
meetings just to organize it uh curating
the issues following up and so that you
know open source projects are tight
really like understaffed under resourced
underfunded and so while
companies who want to um have sprints
is you know it's a good initiative i
think
what companies can consider is to add on
a sort of um
to consider that effort at the top that
goes and finding a way to support that
as well
um so i guess i have a follow-up
question to that do you think
you could maybe put a price on it if the
company
was willing to pay the maintainers or
data umbrella
do you think that would be possible for
you or the maintainers to kind of accept
that and then work with the company on
that
um
yes definitely
and i think that price would that would
be a better discussion to have with the
maintainers because they
would be giving a significant amount of
their time for that but yes the price
could be put on it
um
do you think the work around organizing
sprints is worthy when compared with the
same time dedicated in
hard developing it
could you repeat that please yeah i also
i'm i'm trying
um
if i want to interpret the question
maybe it is do you think the work that
people put around organizing sprints
worth it
you know that is a question that i have
asked myself a number of times
um i would say that knowing
if only i knew then what i know now
which is for sprints to be
a bit more impactful um to commemorate
to commensurate with the effort is if a
let's say if a library has some
structures in place for instance they
have regular community meetings
they have um they have teams outside of
contributing codes such as documentation
teams website teams
social media teams i think that if an
infrastructure is in place for continued
contribution then i would say that
sprints um yes i would say that they do
bring um
value to it this is these are all things
that i wish i had known five six years
ago
um i guess a part of that is also like
by doing this friends
the whole team kind of learns how to do
sprints easier and the materials are
there i guess the first one you and
everybody was a lot more involved in
preparing the
documentation and after a while it
became much easier because you already
have had all those documentations is
that
yeah exactly it um you know and some of
those documentations there's actually a
ver there's a part two of the video that
andy did as well and so whenever
whenever we run a sprint um there's
there's a feedback form that um we send
out and so people give feedback and
there's also feedback via blogs and
twitter and just um very um casual
feedback that they give us organizers
and i make the list of all of that and
then i incorporate it into the next
sprint and as well you know for instance
part two of andy's video answers a lot
of those questions for instance how do
you work on two pr's as
at the same time
um and so um and so yeah we we do learn
a lot along the way i mean i would say
that scikit-learn has learned
a lot over the past five years and so i
can learn is not an easy library to
contribute to and the fact that
so many people have been able to
contribute with you know certain issues
that the maintainers have
um created particularly thomas fan in
terms of you know
validating numpy documentation so people
can get started on an easy issue and
then moving on to more intermediate and
hard issues
nice
any more questions from the ground
if not we thank you very much for the
amazing talk
and thank you